thank you very much evening everyone
welcome to this northwest
area planning committee meeting uh today
wednesday the 18th of november 2020.
my name is maddie thompson and i'm the
chairman of this committee
i hope you'll forgive me looking
sideways i'm actually reading off my
prompt on a separate screen the meeting
is held
under new regulations which came into
effect on the 4th of april in response
to the kobit 19 pandemic
there are just a few housekeeping issues
to run through
first of all could i please ask everyone
present in this meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted and your video
feed off when not addressing the
committee this will reduce background
noises and avoid any unintentional
disturbances
the meeting will be hosted remotely via
conferencing software
this allows members of the public to
attend virtually and
whilst being able to protect themselves
and others and to preserve
i'm sorry observe the government's
lockdown measures
we're streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting
you are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the chat function of the
meeting to indicate if you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time members are reminded
that apart from indicating you wish to
speak
or that you have to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
any other purpose
including questions when speaking and
referring to the gender papers please
ensure you reference a page or paragraph
number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn on your microphone and your video
if
possible now may i ask officers taking
part in the meeting to introduce
themselves starting with mr lee
good evening chairman i'm matthew lee
lead specialist place and chief plan
officer at moore district council
thank you thank you
mr johnson
good evening chairman members my name is
michael johnson i'm the
lead specialist development management
thank you
thank you i'm spells
good evening my name is hannah bowles
i'm a specialist in development
management
thank you and miss fuller
good evening members my name's katie
fuller and i'm clark to this afternoon's
committee
thank you are there any other officers
present who are
taking part in the meeting as distinct
from supporting it
outside okay
um katie could we have a roll call of
members to confirm who is in attendance
yes chairman chairman members i'll call
your name in alphabetical order
please could you indicate if you are
present starting with counsellor durham
president thank you thank you
councillor mrs fleming present
thank you thank you councillor jarvis
evening kts present thank you thank you
counselor keys
good evening kylie good evening
everybody yes i'm present thank you
thank you councillor morley
good evening everyone present thank you
councillor
good evening katie present thank you
councillor mrs thompson
good evening casey and everyone present
white
i haven't seen her i think we better
note her apologies
and hope she's able to come back later i
know because
she works she has difficulty making at
home for some of these meetings at six
sure thank you ask any other members in
attendance if they
could um introduce themselves please
thank you good evening
and welcome in attendance
council morris good evening hello good
evening
good good evening uh katie good evening
members
uh councillor penny channel in
attendance
good evening councillor jana okay
um so item two is apologies for absence
um may i have both please katie and
could we include councillor miss white
just in case uh all we have is uh
councillor miss white
thank you thank you item three is the
minutes of the 21st of october
and it is recommended that the minutes
of the meeting held on 21st of october
this year
found on pages 7 to 10 are approved and
as a true and
accurate record iso move if you wish to
second that motion please
indicate happy to chairman and agree
thank you councillor darum um i would
quite
i would like sorry try again does anyone
have any matters of accuracy to raise
if not can we agree them by ascent
agreed great if anyone
descends really let us know quickly
that's lovely i'll take that as a group
thank you very
uh much next is the
declarations of interest i have to read
this part to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they're also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware
should the needs arise throughout the
meeting if any member has an interest to
declare please use the chat function now
to indicate and i will invite you to
speak
councillor darwin thank you chairman you
read that very fast anyone would think
you're
trying to get the meeting over quickly
um i have a non-cunary interest as a
member of essex county council
who are statutory consultees on uh items
pertaining to these applications thank
you
thank you and council keys i noticed
uh good evening chairman i'm uh i know
the applicant
of the nine i've got the number here
which ends in
well double zero nine one o four um
like many other times i've spoken i have
done haulage for them in a previous
job and i went through young farmers of
the applicants but many years ago now
unfortunately
i'm not as young as i used to be thank
you so that would be just
just to clarify that would be non
non-pecuniary councillor
yeah sorry i didn't say that yeah
non-procurement interest yeah sorry
um i'm not just that very sorry okay i
think that's completed
that part um chair
sorry um and then it's all right council
standing
sorry um i need
i know the applicant i know the
applicant well
so i won't actually be voting uh on that
application thank you okay that's fine
will you be
remaining in the meeting just so we're
all clear on that
sorry i lost you there my sorry will you
be remaining
in the meeting i'll remain but i won't
comment and i won't vote okay thank you
very much thank you for that
uh right now i think we are done so
we're moving on to
item five the planning applications we
have just the one
land adjacent to little tottenham hall
church lane little tottenham
um okay could we have the presentation
please
who's false
thank you chair the planning permission
is so
the demolition of an existing
agricultural building and the
construction of an outbuilding
for use as an annex for dependent
relatives
here we have the block plan you can see
the access here from church lane
this here is the building which is
proposed to be demolished and this is
the main dwelling on site
block plan you can see the proposed
building
and again the main dwelling on sites
we have the floor and elevation plant
plans of the existing
building proposed to be demolished
and the proposed elevation plans
of the annex and the proposed floor plan
you're actually quite faint and there is
anyone else having trouble or is it just
me
no it sounds fine to me gentlemen oh
okay
sorry to introduce you i know that's
fine and we've got some sight
photographs as well here's the
here's the existing building proposed to
be demolished
and the main dwelling in the background
the application is a resubmission of a
previously refused scheme
the proposed scheme is identical to that
previously refused and therefore the
previous reason
for refusal has not been overcome the
proposed attached annex is contrary to
criterion one two and five as set out
within a specialist needs housing
spd and it is not considered to form
ancillary accommodation
the scale of the building distance from
the main dwelling and level of
accommodation
is considered to result in a
self-contained unit of accommodation
without a degree of dependency on the
main dwelling
it is not considered that there would be
a functional link between the proposed
residential unit and the main dwelling
the inherent domestication intrusion and
intensification of an unjustified
residential unit at the site
is considered to harm the character and
appearance of the site and result in the
erosion of the rural character of the
countryside
it's not considered that the slight
amendment to the applicant's supporting
statement
has overcome the conflict with the
development plan highlighted
by the council when refusing the
previous
identical planning application therefore
the application is recommended for
refusal
thank you chair thank you can i just
confirm with no
speakers on this public speakers
okay um right i'm going to remove the
recommendation
and i'm going to ask someone to second
it now just
for clarity for anyone who's listening
just because you proposed or seconded
motion does not oblige you to vote for
it um
it is a matter of form in order to have
a proposal on the table to debate so
with someone second please
counselor durham german i'm happy to if
it's a procedural matter that's fine
thank you
yes thank you very much okay members um
i do have counselor keys hand up to
speak but council still called it in
so i'll go to him first unless he'd
rather wait
council siddal know i'm quite happy to
talk first
no i'm happy with richard said speak
first
thank you joe okay right council
officer uh yeah this uh i understand
this application has
been uh before the council previously
but it wasn't called into this committee
at that particular time
uh in terms of the application it is
it is one of those ones that you can see
good reasons for it being refused
and also i believe there are good
reasons for perhaps
that it should be approved it's not a
new
building it is an existing building and
the existing building
is of a dilapidated nature
now in terms of the uh occupation of
that building
i know it's not a material consideration
but it would be used for
family members in terms of that
situation
and it does meet i understand uh
what ms bowles said about it doesn't
meet all of the criteria in terms of
being an annex but it does meet quite a
lot
of the criteria in terms of being an
annex
the uh issue obviously is it's not
next to the main dwelling
in terms of it being an intensification
i would question that one because uh
it is an existing building and it's
hidden by a very large barn from
the uh listed church which is the
closest building to it so
you you can't actually see this building
from the church and the main building
that you can see from the church is a
horrendous building it's a it's a
it's a large agricultural building so i
i can't see it being an intensification
yeah
to me this is something where i think it
would enhance
uh the site because
we the applicant is repairing a
dilapidated building
so yeah in terms of the balance there is
a mixture of balance in in terms of this
application
i think it would it would in in terms of
d1
it would enhance uh the design and
quality
of the area so therefore that would be a
positive
um in terms of this particular building
i think what the applicant is trying to
do and the reason why
it is such a large and it is a large
annex is they are trying to reuse
an existing building so hence why it
ends up being quite a large building
and at this stage that's all i've got to
say thank you
um the next hand i have up is councillor
durham and
councillor keys you've taken yours away
so you're going to wait a minute still
thank
um uh councillor just just
made some extremely good points but he
did say that the the scale of it was due
to the
um the size of the existing building
but i thought this was for to demolish
the existing building
is that correct through uk
okay so it's cut its existing sizes you
know it's actually irrelevant
okay could you also tell me how many
meters it is from the
the host dwelling
you know it would be very hypocritical
of me not to raise the fact that this is
contrary to the ldp
it would establish a really very
difficult precedent for us
um you know are you to go against the
ldp but also to draw a line in the sand
about the distance that the
annex is to its host building i think
that we're on
you know very uh thin ice there
and that's the reason that it was
previously rejected by this
um by this authority um
you know we we have won an appeal in the
last few days
um upholding uh on the basis of its
country to the ldp
and and absolutely we we need to follow
that
otherwise we're going to be putting
future appeal decisions in jeopardy
um but yeah i do see positive sides to
it but i think um the policy is enough
to
to uphold the officer's recommendation
thank you
thank you um could i have a comment
from you mr lee on on that are you
ready to do that would you like to do
that
thank you so much technological issues i
was clicking and it didn't
be registering
made a couple of points that quite
correct i think there's
multi-layered uh level of issues on
council has you know broke the point of
the policy um but i'd go back to a
little bit before that
where um council highlights the fact
that the current building is a certain
level of
uh degradation and poor uh quality
currently the building is now cultural
building um
it's an accepted fact by everybody you
know that all buildings particularly
maybe some that aren't built for as long
permanently have a certain life
time and just always highlight
members attention to this matter that a
building only has a life
period and you know just because a
building is appearing tired and maybe
slightly to
the detriment of kept here we shouldn't
just embrace
allowing almost anything to replace it
um
because once granted permission we have
to look at the lifetime of this new
development so
just because an existing you know we
have this put forward a lot by agents as
well as obviously be conscious
if not just this application but full
applications that
just because especially in our culture
building is coming to the end of its
life doesn't mean we should
automatically allow
a new form of development whether it's a
house whether it's a commercial
building or whatever but obviously just
need to be conscious that
just because one building is coming into
his life doesn't mean plant fish is
automatically granted for a new
development
notwithstanding this council highlights
the spd and the various points within it
and
it's fact that this does uh meet a
number of the
policy requirements and i think ms
bolt's report in
section 5.1 covers this very well
um i said a number of points it does
meet um
officers are concerned by the distance
from the dwelling
for it to be an annex there needs to be
an ancillary nature
it's not that it's a primary residence
that just happens to be in the cartilage
because that would actually form a
separate planning unit
and if that was to remain for more than
four years or ten years if we impose a
condition
that would become a breach planning
child was unable to be defended at
appeal
so just because someone says they want
to use an annex if they don't use it as
an annex
we have to think about that and we do
get challenged on this through law
development certificates and enforcement
breaches quite a lot and
arguments about what is ancillary and
what isn't
um so that is something 28 meters you
need to be able to look at how would
that
ancillary nature happen would there be a
daily relationship would meals be taken
in
the main dwelling would there be shared
recreational space all things like that
which officers think at 28 meters it's
unlikely that would be
um it's unlikely that would happen which
is further exacerbated though by two
points one being
the level of residential accommodation
obviously if it was just a
a bedroom with a an ensuite obviously
it's much more likely that mills and
everything else will incur in the main
dwelling more
more residential uh space there is less
likely that's to occur
and thirdly which is a slightly unusual
point but
is highlighted in the office report at
section 5.1.7
the future occupies annex live in fairly
close proximity to this property already
and there hasn't been any explanation
how or why this needs to be in annex or
how this would change the relationship
back to you of the current situation of
just two separate planning units
two different dwellings um understand
you know things change and material
considerations and
relationships alter but if the applicant
hasn't explained or put forward any
argument to why this would have
actually now have an ancillary
relationship and what would be different
between the current situation which is
two totally different residential units
which would mean if this was to carry on
going forward would just be
instantly a breach of planning control
and obviously if we were to impose a
condition
that doesn't meet the six tests its
ultraviolets would fall away so
which obviously is a concern that
officers always
raise um and as councillor durham said
i'm not quite sure of the
argument that just because a building is
currently this size if it's being
demolished and replaced why a future
building needs to be of the exact same
size um
but hopefully i think i've covered the
points for you chairman if not please
care fine i'll
happily thank you thank you thank you
very much uh well
we might be back but i have council keys
followed by council of jarvis so capsule
keys first please
oh good evening thank you um excuse me
um
judge every application on the merits in
front of you now um
yeah old agricultural building we're
here again another planning application
on another old redundant barn it's not
fit for purpose in today's
life the way that farming has carried on
and
matt has now he's already spoken about
it but i thought we had to judge on what
is in front of us but
the applicants do live across the other
side of the churchyard
and i remember back when the farm
cottages at the front there was two
cottages knocked down to build the one
crafter so they
automatically gave up one residential
development
and this in the farm yard is just across
the drive from the farmhouse
and yes i believe 28 meters a meal would
not be cold the time it walked across
there
so i do think it is definitely there to
be looked after
the building will never be sold away
from the farm because it's right in the
middle of the farm yard
so knock it down use the same spaces
there it's right next door to an
agricultural barn
it's not worth hardly anything to the
outside person to buy because it's next
to an agricultural one and it
never ever come up because it's in the
middle of a farm you'll now
judge it on the merit that's in front of
it i think i'll go against the officers
i know matt lee is now going to
be renting and raving but um that's what
i'm being led to believe and i
should we should judge him on the infant
and i think i would put a proposal that
this should be
passed right well we
we have a proposal on the table so we'll
doubtless come back to that
should we need to council jarvis
thank you uh i've spotted this evolution
point as well i think that's been
clarified obviously we have to judge
the application in front of us it would
seem if the
current building is being demolished
that obviously a smaller property
smaller annex could be built in in its
place instead of perhaps a
larger one which is proposed but um
nevertheless obviously
that's what they've proposed and that's
the application we're looking at
this evening i i don't have a problem
with the distance
i'm not sure if there are sort of rules
on the distance it probably depends as
i think uh as counselor keys says this
is in a sort of farmyard setting
28 meters isn't uh isn't uh
a large uh distance uh
if you're talking about buildings and
outbuildings um
i i've i've got out buildings that are
much much further away three times
uh further away um i think um so i'm not
so worried about the distance at all
uh i think um uh
it's is it possible to
could i could i ask if through youtube
could ask
um obviously to comment on whether
you know this concern about it only
being used as an annex and obviously not
having its own dining facilities kitchen
that sort of thing
and it's being put forward as an annex
so i assume they looked into the rules
and
that's what they intend to use it for
now it may well be that the family
circumstances are
as it's a family um that they're very
happy to use it as an annex you know
just somewhere to sleep
and obviously the family come and all
eat in the main house i mean
um as an annex is it possible if there's
a concern that it might be two
properties to
to impose a condition and say well it
must be used as an annex
you can't uh can't have a kitchen and
it's a dining room northern
i mean couldn't that just be a condition
i don't unders is that something
perhaps i understand that
fall away has not been reasonable when
i'm going to come back to mr lee but one
of the points is we have to look
for the lifetime of the development
which is 50 or 100 years away and we
won't be talking about the same families
well not
the same family but you want the same
family members but
uh let me come ask mr lee to come in uh
thank you chairman um so science said
yep you've covered the point there's um
there is the issue of whether or not
condition can be imposed um
there's there's no
issue per se with the amount of
residential accommodation the purest
sense there's nothing that says you
um you can't have all the facilities
available for day-to-day living
um it's quite acceptable to have that
but that's one of the balancing factors
in coming to whether or not a proposal
is acceptable
obviously if something was a five
bedroom you know two
you know it'd be very difficult to argue
it's an annex but the first point of
consideration is is
it if it's to be an annex it has to be
ancillary
so one obviously is the fact is is
solely is the ability to actually
function as an independent dwelling but
as i said just because you do
doesn't mean that it or it has just
because it does have those facilities
doesn't mean it should be refused
automatically
one of the others is the likelihood and
its relationship with the main dwelling
and so that's where for example our old
sp
old policy which fell away part of the
local camera review actually required
that it
was an attached to the main dwelling um
and integral
personally i thought that was too over
the top one of a better phrase and i'm
quite happy that that has fallen away
because i don't necessarily agree with
that
as a principle but it just does allow
officers and members and decision maker
to
take a more pragmatic and reasonable
approach um
i acknowledge what you're saying
counselor jarvis about 28 meters isn't
far from an outbuilding
and i don't disagree with that but what
you've got to look at is is 28 meters
far
too far for you to be proactively likely
to walk there
to get your cup of coffee in the morning
in the rain would it be unlikely for you
to think i'll go and watch the tv
with the family in the rain at the dark
at night at un
unattractive hours it's about the
ability to have an ancillary
relationship
rather than a incidental relationship
you know
or an independent relationship just
because there is interaction at some
level doesn't mean it's ancillary
and i think your point about outbuilding
is very different to an annex
per se where an instant you would you
know you go to your garage once
a day or something if you don't have to
do you won't or you're forced to
it's it's a balancing exercise there is
a big difference that's what's all i
would advise
you you come across as a bit lazy there
obviously
it's not always raining it's not always
tough
i regularly go much further than that
for a cup of tea i can assure you
but thank you for your comments thank
you jamie
um okay thank you do we have anyone else
wishing to speak um counselor jarvis
just
for completeness would you um
thank you i'm noticing we're getting
some comments in the chat which
um i would be grateful if people would
stop not least because members of the
public can't see it
um so i think we have time to move to a
vote and i did
put the proposal um of the
recommendation to refuse
so katie could you take the vote please
on the recommendation to refuse
yes chairman so we are voting to refuse
the application as
per the officer's recommendation members
i'll take your name in alphabetical
order please could you indicate whether
you are for against or of stay
starting with councillor durham please
for the officer recommendation thank you
thank you
councillor jarvis
i'm against thank you
councillor keys i'm also against
thank you councillor morley
against thank you councillor
against thank you counselor mrs thompson
four for the recommendation thank you
chairman
that is two four four against
and no abstentions thank you so that
fails
um could i please have a proposal i was
like councillor keys who's gonna put the
proposal but
um as well as the proposal which
i guess what it's gonna be because it's
going to be to approve but we need
reasons for approval and um i'll be
i'll be needing to check with mr lee
that um
they satisfy the legal requirements
okay that's the keys
i think uh hello can you hear me oh well
i'll i'll
afford it to be approved and um
d1 there was already a building there
and i don't think it's detriment to the
area or the village scene or what
whatever they said there i can't
remember what the terminology was to the
rural location that's it
it's not temperamental a real location
i'll leave mr siddills councillor said
i've got anything
are you content with that reason for
refusal would you like to add anything
and see if councillor keys will
avoid your extras so i i would suggest
that
uh that the design and quality of the
new building
will enhance the uh environment
and uh the uh
the the fact that we are reusing an
exist
an existing site and that it does meet
most of the criteria of being
a uh a annex
for the main property i'll second all
that
thank you you just proposed as long as
you're happy to adopt um councillor
siddal's suggestions into your original
i'm more than happy to he's already
seconded since then his ideas i'm sure
he's going to carry on seconding it
um mr lee does that satisfy uh legal
overdoses
as always it's within the gift of
decision maker all i would highlight
that
i've got a couple of concerns in the
fact that you've implied that
any building that's detrimental
should can be replaced automatically and
the bigger problem i would flag is that
you've acknowledged the application does
not meet requirements of the
policy but you're saying that to a
certain extent that doesn't matter
there's no
doesn't appear to be any things that
outweigh the harm
therefore your this would be a very
dangerous decision for any future
applications on
annexes because they would just be able
to quote back
this decision to say that actually an
annex does not need to meet all of our
policy requirements to be acceptable
so i'll just be very conscious of the
wording that's used thank you chairman
so mr lee or or
uh balls sorry
um yeah can is it possible to use some
of that
policy in terms of passing
this application surely when we when
we're passing an application it doesn't
always meet every single element of
criteria
thank you chairman um i would say most
instances officers will be saying it
does and if it doesn't
we clearly explain in our offices report
what why there isn't harm so let's say
it needed to provide a hundred metres
squared and it's providing 98 garden
we in the office report it would clearly
state that a two meter shortfall is not
considered to be so
onerous or injurious to uh warrant a
reason for refusal
so um but obviously what i would say is
that councillor jarvis is
in his opinion and obviously this was he
wasn't the person that recommended
uh it wasn't put forward the motion but
his
stance was that actually it was policy
compliant in relation to
the spd um which is a
subjective matter and obviously each
application must be determined on its
own merit
i would encourage you i would never
encourage members on
any policy to say it hasn't met some of
the criteria but we aren't worried about
that for one of a better phrase because
that just is something that can be used
against us time and again so i believe
that members listen you did say today
that planning is half subjective and
half rule
so yeah that that subjective distance so
if we say that it is compliant in terms
of you know that it is
is in proximity of the main building
yeah and as i said councillor jarvis
sorry to
be cancelled but just to back out that
um
and he was talk sorry chairman yes um
i apologize it's much harder than when
it's committed
um but yeah as i'm saying obviously you
know each application is determined on
its own merit as
i think i think if it was counselor keys
were saying you know the
location it's unlikely that it would be
subdivided there may well be a much
closer relationship
so there have been points discussed
tonight about around that point
but it's just not that about actually
that it was acceptable in this instance
not that it wasn't me in the policies
which is obviously slightly different to
what council syd will put forward so
that's all i would just highlight to
members
okay if i could come back please check
yes i think i would look
less on it if they put in an application
to build a new
building nearer to the house they are
using a building that was already there
i know they're knocking it down but
i would be less favorable if they're
putting a brand new place up much closer
to the house i think
on this they're using a building okay
that's all i've got to say thank you
well i've got councillor durham who i
think might be about to offer something
helpful
well i'm trying to try it yeah can we
can you say something like that i can
hardly hear you mark
but
thank you that's better um yeah due to i
think
what how about something aligned with
due to the
the location of this building within the
main site
it's more acceptable than had you know
if it was on the
the uh the boundary which would mean
it's more easily divided up
due to the nature of the fact that it's
in the middle of a
um a farm site uh it's that's a
reason for it being acceptable uh and
contrary to policy
mr lee i'm sure you can make something
you know where i'm coming from
yeah so you chairman um yeah obviously
um counselor dom's obviously just put
forward some
positive aspects of development which
make you know
members may consider that overcome some
conflict with the policy
um obviously it's within their gift
obviously that is a lot more balanced so
it's we're not saying that we just it
hasn't met
it and that's fine what we're saying is
that although there may have been some
conflict
there were benefits that outweighed the
harm
so okay i've got to
just say due to the location of the the
proposed building within the the uh
the site as a whole right
okay can now we've had a lot of debate
about what the proposal is and funnily
enough our training on chairing is that
we don't
we don't do that if we can help it
nevertheless it's not the officer's
job and in fact we can't even ask them
to come up with reasons for refusal when
they've just recommended
reason for approval when they're just
recommended we don't
so can i from perhaps counselor
what counselor keys or counsellor said
i'll have the actual wording of your
reasons for approval because i we've got
to make this as simple as possible
okay so my reasons my reasons for
approval are due to the nature and the
proximity
and site layout of the property
it does meet the criteria for
uh being an annex to the main dwelling
yeah i think that's good that works
yeah council keys all right with that
uh yeah i'm fine i can't think there's
anything else just
using a builder being built on the same
footprint so yeah
uh okay
those two things then are you all right
with have you got that
katie it's all got a bit i know it's a
bit
confusing yes i've got that thank you as
long as you're clear that's absolutely
fine
so we now have a proposal to approve for
the i'm not going to try and read it out
reasons as um laid out by
councillor sigel who seconded counsellor
case's proposal could we have a vote on
that place
oh counselor durham you've got your hand
up is that a legacy hand
intellectually it was it certainly was
and uh or i'm
called i will abstain on that uh
motion thank you okay
because you were first weren't you so
can we carry on with the roll call
having had an extension from councillor
darwin
yep um so members
members um i will take your names in
alphabetical order please could you
indicate whether you are fought against
or abstain
starting with councillor durham please
sorry i
i i jumped the gun miss fuller so but i
will abstain please thank you
jarvis
yeah thank you katie i'm uh for that uh
recommendation thank you thank you
councillor keys
i'm four thank you councillor morley
here for the recommendation
thank you councillor four
thank you councillor mrs thompson i'm
against
you that is four four
two against and no abstentions
right um it's slightly written well more
than slightly remiss of me what we
didn't do was look at the
conditions um can i have your agreement
everyone on standard conditions
and delegate the rest to the officers
does that work for you mr lee yep that
works for me thank you
and if we can ensure that yeah
any design is within keeping and the
materials used
of of matching the existing yes and
could we have those come back
for the ward members as well as me for
approval yes
that's just what i was going to say
about the award members please yeah
that's fine
okay right that's lovely that is that
chairman so i decided um could we just
go back to casey and
just make sure we recorded that vote
correctly i thought counselor darren rub
stay
but he did yes i think apologies
yes okay
thank you could you just repeat the
numbers katie for us
yeah it is four four one against and one
abstention
thank you that sounds right okay thank
you that is
agreed and it's approved in line with uh
discussions i'm not going to try and
spell it out
uh gender item six is any other items of
business the chairman of the committee
decides that urgent and there are none
so item seven the closure of the meeting
um
members thank you for your contributions
this evening and thank you to the
officers for their support
i now draw the meeting to a close at
1841